[Music]
after sending a note begging for help
help to a restaurant through grubhub
wow
what do you mean
so like she used the the the app to be
like hey
can i have more forks no cilantro and
help
additional instructions
please call the police
he's going to call me when you delivered
come with the cones please don't make it
obvious okay but pause nobody ever reads
those oh because i make notes in those
and nobody ever reads those how long are
you know like she got a really good girl
that's true she's got a five star you
know what i find out
because it depends on who's picking it
up because you know how like sometimes
drivers will do like multiple different
apps right
and then i remember i sent in a note and
then the dude showed me on the other
side he goes man this is how they [ __ ]
us and i'm like why he goes because not
all the apps
show that when you put it in
so i'm like so like i said you do
grubhub and then like [ __ ] whatever
uber eats or whatever and then like the
person that's picking it up might not
see it
i'm like that's where they [ __ ] you
so the note is not necessary for the
delivery person it's for the restaurant
yeah
so yeah this woman was saved from the
kidnappers also lazy as [ __ ] because
that was like
oh you put in your order yeah yeah it's
like what the don't call the cops
which means that
it wasn't really a kidnapping it sounds
like a domestic abuse thing yes
like when ladies be like i'm gonna order
pizza after you beat me up
hello yeah i'm just getting dinner uh
can i get a pepperoni pizza and my
police
oh i just said please please please
so this happened in the bronx uh in new
york uh this lady sent this note to a
local restaurant through grubhub
ordering uh asking them to call the
police the chipper truck cafe in yonkers
new york wrote on its facebook page that
it helped save a woman from a five-hour
hostage situation wednesday morning wow
she ordered a delivery through grubhub
to our restaurant and added this note
the restaurant wrote on facebook
alongside a photo of the note she wrote
that i shall and did undercover come in
as a grub hub guy
he comes and just throws her food at the
front door and runs away
[Laughter]
there is no grubhub uniform so uh the
victim had ordered an irish breakfast
sandwich and a cheeseburger to accompany
her uh alarming note the chipper truck
cafe wrote our staff responded
immediately and called the police and
she got saved
police said a 32 year old man was
arrested at 6 30 a.m and charged with
rape
strangulation we're gonna have fun with
this one wow criminal sex act unlawful
imprisonment
uh menacing assault criminal possession
of a weapon and sexual abuse you just
made it too real it's like such a
lighthearted like hey this grub-up thing
zany way to rescue
oh yeah she was raped
by the way there's the kicker
i'll omit information that makes you
uncomfortable next time
well i wait was this uh
someone intruded or was it like her
boyfriend and they got some weird [ __ ]
or what happened that's a lot of counts
i believe it's so messy but i'm not sure
but uh or maybe that's a shitload of
charges actually it doesn't say they're
all like the craziest stuff it could be
a break-in yeah it could have been yeah
but then that's even dumber why would
you yeah why did you pass it with the
[ __ ] why would you pass the phone and be
like order a girl usually they're not
like yeah because he was mentally maybe
he slept because it's like six in the
morning i'm like dang dude five hours
right so there must have been some time
where she probably snuck away and thank
goodness for new york having food 24
hours that's true imagine if this should
happen in a small town or something and
it's like man you got to wait till
things so this was like 5 a.m order or
something like that oh [ __ ] and then
police ended up arresting the guys so it
was overnight [ __ ] this guy's crazy oh
you hungry here let's get some breakfast
you better not go anywhere else okay
[Laughter]
really lucky because not only does
somebody read it but it's also five in
the morning yeah
somebody usually coming into work
they're like stoned imagining kidnaps
they go driving and he was like ask that
cop for directions just directions
only my dumbass would be like i would
only ask directions you seem that way
what's that um
we kind of i think we did article on
this what's that like hand sign or
something like that that like oh it's
this oh we all forgot though oh bummer
wait that's important what's that thing
that helps you i'm in your you you
should know you have a kid
what is it do you have a kid too i
wasn't here for the article i wasn't
even article either all right what is
this but it doesn't have a b it's like
if you're if you're being held captive
or you need help but you can't say
anything you just do this with your hand
or some [ __ ] and it means be oh i was
just doing sign language
with alphabet i think that i think the
article that we had covered was like a a
child had been abducted and then like in
the car like was doing it handsome and
somebody had recognized that this being
like the signal for that kind of
situation and was able to call wrestling
i don't think that's common knowledge
that's why kid did that to me i would
have been like only
only kidnappers know that yeah yeah only
people that abduct children only
kidnappers know this [ __ ] though i put
that aside but that's why it's important
here at jk news that we bring up these
conversations good
doesn't do the legitimized jk like that
dude don't illegitimize it is that also
so that if you have to shake someone's
hand and they feel your thumb
can you go like this i don't know that
means like i'm in trouble i thought
you'd do it like this yeah
yeah that works don't do that next to me
dude don't legitimize that
legit doesn't that mean i'll suck your
dick oh my god on the low
i hope that's not two meanings because
that's really i thought that was a
politician's handshake of like meet you
in the bathroom later buddy
that's one of them that you know that's
the mixture wait so this is the host i'm
sorry i need help that's the i need help
i wish we had a laptop in here
that's one of them there's a yeah
because there's a
there's a commercial for it where it
shows a what are you even called it's
like a woman on a webcam and she's like
chatting and then the husband's like
behind her like doing something so she's
like talking and then she goes okay see
you later
and then
and then it says like no the signals or
something it's like a little oh it's
like a psa it's like a psa for you more
of those okay more of those you know my
dumb ass is going to go like this i
volunteer and then i'll probably go like
this like that we're just not doing this
oh you know what i think it is i think
it's this and then you close it it's
something like this
this this was taught to this chick this
kidnapped girl was rescued after she
learned this on tick tock
she learned this on tick tock and she
showed this sign so you just showed this
with your thumb inside your fist i'm
guessing it means like you're yeah you
have to go you have to go like this and
then close it the whole motion oh my
heart yeah it's rough so what does this
mean then i don't know that you're about
to be kidnapped this means it's done
it's done this is a done deal you [ __ ]
up man what if you get kidnapped and you
don't know you forget
but you have to see you have to see this
this is the more important part because
you could just lose a [ __ ] fist right
so
you have to show that it's in and then
you close it yeah the closing to like
symbolize that it's there so it's all
the perspective then cause what if
you're on the wrong angle now it's just
a threat
you go hey that kid's about to punch
that adult
get him
saved so if you're like this does this
mean that you're you escaped
that means you're good yeah that means
you talk good escape or i need a ride
because you're doing the webcam right
you're like this
and then you hear them leave and you're
like oh [ __ ] okay i'm about to escape
but then they come back in like
that means someone's gonna throw you a
[ __ ] fastball at any moment now
you're just i'm sure you're like um
there's umpire behind you
[Laughter]
illegal signals ejection
damn that's so scary man
i think it's important to think about
and recognize those different signs [ __ ]
yeah dude otherwise we got joe just
[ __ ] looking at other kids like
i know i tried to talk to tyke about all
that [ __ ] like just the other day i was
telling him like okay if a stranger
tries to talk to you what do you tell
him and he goes i'm not supposed to talk
to strangers i'm like nah dude you just
[ __ ] go away i don't because i don't
bet i'm just like you just run away
and then so we like drill it we like to
practice remember we were walking on
that trail and that family said hi and
he was i'm not supposed to talk to
strangers but that's the right energy
that's true and that's cute coming from
a four-year-old yeah yeah yeah that's
cute yeah teaching him like sock in the
dick and like how to escape and like all
these like little maneuvers you practice
on dad
no that's nowhere to be found
he's an absent fall on the ground like
you're dead
maybe dad is
yeah kidnapper i don't know where that
is are you okay yeah we don't care
that's not a kid so he's more like
you know what i mean
there's also like people that are really
just good at being able to tell
something's wrong which is [ __ ] great
like there's that one thing that
happened really recently too at a
restaurant where the uh the kid it was
like a kid eating with his dad and then
the kid had visible like marks
and that's all it took and the server
just went behind the dad made eye
contact with the kid and went
and the kid just went
yeah or something really simple and then
she called the cops and they found out
that the dad was beating this kid's ass
for weeks
weeks yeah like [ __ ]
consistently oh i thought this meant no
problem
don't want trouble
i don't wanna travel imagine she goes oh
okay
apple fritter's coming up in just a
second
[Music]
you